are you ready for the best week of your
life
[Applause]
[Music]
how was everybody's first full day of
camp
this whole thing isn't really my scene
I'm back
I'm Noah
with a no
okay
[Music]
you are in with the aardvarks we used to
have a bit of a bladder control problem
anyway the child prodigy who just
described by his computer teacher as
potentially problematic I'm Mallory
since you asked Somebody's gotta cry
I do not have a crush he's had a lot to
overcome in his life stop that kid
a little punk you know what the judge
said after your last request Last Chance
blah blah blah whatever
dust up at the climbing wall knock it
off
you saw a magical video game from a
bunch of gangsters we're going to that
camp and we're gonna get what's ours
when I get my hands on that kid
you don't think some people are beyond
help what are you guys doing here we're
all here for you
does everyone remember what to do and if
you trust and rely on your friends you
might just find it'll change your whole
life hey turkeys I'm up here
[Music]
we all followed our own path to arrive
here in this moment think about
care about you
[Music]
I got him Charlie